[Applause]
27 Seasons nearly 5 000 episodes
countless outrageous moments and fights
and if guests weren't throwing punches
they were throwing food Jerry loved a
good food fight and his Thanksgiving
special left all the family drama out on
the table
nothing was off limits that included a
pig love triangle
and a man marrying a horse
he said I better come out and say it I
left my wife and two children for a
Shetland pony I'm getting nervous that
horse is staring at me
the show had such an impact on pop
culture that in 1998 he got the big
screen treatment in ring Master Jerry
played a fictional version of himself
show okay in 2015 he was among the many
celebs who made a cameo in Sharknado 3.
please please take my picture
but the talk show King was mostly
featured doing what he does best in
shows like Sabrina the Teenage Witch and
The Simpsons there's only
settle an argument this bizarre
how did it feel to learn your baby was
fathered by a drooling space octopus it
made me angry Jerry being on The
Simpsons that was honestly the first
time I noticed that oh my gosh people
are really noticing it he also tried
helping Dr Evil reconnect with his son
in Austin Powers The Spy Who shagged me
why'd you run out on me
because you're not quite evil enough
obviously that ended in true Jerry
Springer fashion
[Applause]
listen Jerry Springer really did it all
politician talk show host movie star he
was a true renaissance man we want to
leave you with something that Jerry did
at the end of every show his final
thought rest in peace Jerry take care
everyone
know this there's never been a moment in
the 25 years of doing this show that I
ever thought I was better than the
people who appear in our stage I'm not
better only lucky
and on that note take care of yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you